hey everyone I just want to make a quick
video sharing the fact that I'm about to
play an over-the-board classical event
I'm at the kregero resort in Norway
currently even though it kind of feels
like I'm in heaven with all this uh
backlights coming through the window but
um yeah I'm super excited for this event
I have not played a classical event for
several months the last one I played was
in Abu Dhabi in August I'll link that
playlist below I do recap all my games
from that event
um but coming up uh in just a couple
hours I will be playing the first round
and let me share the information about
this event the time control is 90
minutes with a 30 second comments so
much slower paced compared to what I
usually play online and
um there will be nine rounds so there
are chances for Grand Master Norms which
I do questions about all the time and
here we see the player list uh I'm
currently the 20 money something seed
there's a good handful of grand Masters
and there will be Norm opportunities now
I don't have any Grand Master Norms
currently but if I do really well maybe
I can get my my first Norm still very
very far away from the GM title so
really my goal here is just to play
interesting exciting and hopefully high
quality chess and hopefully have a lot
to share with the YouTube viewers so we
can see there are
I think over 100 players at least in the
title group which I'll be competing in
and all my games should be broadcast
online so as soon as I know the link for
the live broadcast I will share it in
the video description
um so shortly after this video is
released you'll be able to watch my
games hopefully in in real time although
there might be a broadcast delay which
is kind of becoming the standard these
days and yeah I'm hoping to do Recaps
throughout the events so be sure to
subscribe if you want to see those now
there are two games a day for the
majority of days in this event and my
top priorities are eating sleeping
preparing and staying awake for my games
but if I have time to fit in the Recaps
I certainly will so very soon the
pairings will go up I might as well
check right now
Kings have not yet been posted so still
have to wait but uh but yeah wish me
luck if you have questions leave them
below and I'll see you guys soon